bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat c'est aujourd'hui que
nicolas dufour que le directeur général
de la bpi la banque publique
d'investissement doit présenter sa
stratégie aux parlementaires il est
entendu ce matin par les sénateurs de la
commission des finances
je vous rappelle que la bpi était le
premier des 60 engagements de campagne
de françois hollande
cette nouvelle banque dispose d'une
force de frappe de 42 milliards d'euros
pourtant son champ d'intervention n'est
pas tout à fait défini récemment nicolas
dufourcq avait en effet créé la
polémique en déclarant que sauver
petroplus souffle orange n'aurait pas
été un bon business pour la bpi ce qui
avait suscité la colère de ségolène
royal qui est également vice-présidente
de cette banque publique
d'investissement pour elle au contraire
la bpi doit prendre des risques alors
pour en savoir plus sur la stratégie de
la banque publique d'investissement tout
de suite direction la salle clémenceau
bonne matinée à tous l'article 12 de la
loi du 30 et 31 décembre 2012 relative à
la création de la banque publique
d'investissement prévoit qu'un mois
avant sa présentation conseil
d'administration le directeur général
ici présents monsieur dufourcq présente
aux commissions permanentes compétentes
du parlement le projet de doctrine
d'intervention de la société anonyme bpi
group ou me corriger si je fais des
erreurs c'est conformément à cette
disposition législative que les trois
commissions permanentes du sénat
l'éminente commission des finances ont
présenté à la fois par son vice
président et rapporteur général
la commission du développement durable
ainsi que ma commission stade la
commission des affaires économiques
sont aujourd'hui réunies monsieur le
directeur général pour vous auditionnés
monsieur dufour que vous avez été nommée
la tête du groupe b pays par un décret
du président de la république du 7
février dernier cette nomination
s'inscrit je le rappelle dans la
continuité des fonctions qui vous
avaient été confiées précédemment
puisque dès l'automne le ministre de
l'économie vous avez demandé de conduire
une mission de préfiguration de la bpi
lors du premier conseil d'administration
qui s'est réuni à dijon on se demande
pourquoi le 21 février
non mais la moutarde me monte vraiment
vous avez été vous avez présenté la
feuille de route que vous entendez
suivent pour structurer la bpi dans les
meilleurs délais peut-être pourrez-vous
nous indiquer brièvement les principales
étapes déjà franchies et préciser le
calendrier des rendez vous à venir
en effet si les éléments de base de la
nouvelle structure existait déjà
je pense évidemment à oseo
je pense à cdc entreprises et je pense
aussi aux fsi et donc que pour mettre en
place mais pays france reste malgré tout
un chantier complexe il faut créer les
deux filiales du groupe à savoir bpi
france financement et bpi france
investissement ce qui implique notamment
de se mettre d'accord sur l'évaluation
des apports des deux actionnaires
il faut obtenir les agréments
nécessaires ou le feu vert des autorités
de régulation concernées
qu'il s'agisse de l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel de l'autorité des marchés
financiers ou de l'autorité de la
concurrence compétentes pour le contrôle
des fusions une notification de la
commission européenne est également
nécessaire
il faut créer les organes de gouvernance
qui au niveau national et régional
permettront de coordonner l'action de la
bpi avec les stratégies de développement
des régions
enfin c'est plus précisément l'objet de
l'audition d'aujourd'hui il faut définir
la doctrine d'intervention du nouveau
groupe
le deuxième conseil d'administration
s'est tenu le 22 avril
son ordre du jour portait précisément
sur cette question de la doctrine avant
que vous nous en présenter les
principaux éléments je tiens à souligner
que pendant cette période transitoire la
bpi travail à travers les actions
traditionnelles de oséo et des filiales
de la caisse des dépôts qui se
poursuivent en principe sans rupture de
continuité mais vous nous le confirmer
nous avons veillé lors des débats
parlementaires à ce que les dispositions
transitoires robuste permettent cette
continuité d'actions c'est indispensable
compte tenu du contexte économique et
des besoins des entreprises en
particulier des pme
je regarde monsieur bourque en même
temps mieux depuis le début de l'année
la bpi a lancé plusieurs nouveaux
produits à destination des entreprises
je pense aux préfinancements du cic eux
à la garantie renforcement de la
trésorerie auprès pour l'innovation ou
encore au préfinancement du crédit impôt
recherche
c'est ainsi un total de 630 millions de
d'euros qui est en cours de versement
aux pme de tei montant qui s'ajoute
évidemment au soutien courant apportée
par la bpi france investissement et bp
et bpi france financement je donne
maintenant la parole à monsieur et
albéric de montgolfier en tant que vice
président de la commission des finances
monsieur raymond vall présidents des
commissions du développement durable
pour compléter ce propos introductif
ensuite monsieur le directeur général
vous aurez seule la parole pour nous
présenter le projet doctrine
d'intervention de la bpi france
je vous propose qu'à l'issue de cette
présentation que les trois rapporteurs
sur le projet de loi puisse vous
interrogez en priorité à savoir monsieur
françois marc rapporteur général et
rapporteur au fond du texte monsieur
martial bourquin rapporteur pour avis
pour notre commission et monsieur vers
eto'o pour le développement durable
le directeur général que vous êtes
pourrait alors leur répondre et ensuite
on ouvrira les demandes de prise de
parole
monsieur de montgolfier vous avez seule
la parole merci c'est extrêmement bref
je voudrais monsieur le président
messieurs les rapporteurs généraux mes
chers collègues salue monsieur dufour je
vous rappellerai que le parlement et le
sénat singulièrement ceux représentés au
sein du comité national d'orientation de
la bpi puisque avec ma collègue michel
andré nous avons été nommés par le
président du sénat au sein de ce comité
national d'orientation qui se réunit une
fois à caen sera plus en province pour
les raisons que vous connaissez
moi je voudrais tout simplement d'abord
bien vouloir près d'excusés philippe
marini qui ne peut être présent cette
édition et vous dire que cette audition
elle était voulue par le parlement sur
la doctrine intervention c'est ce que
nous avions souhaité dans la loi et je
vais pas retarder plus connu de retard
le l'audition j'aurais simplement une
question qui portera sur l'actualité qui
portent notamment sur la cession de la
bourse de paris de d'euronext très
concrètement est ce que vous savez le
new york times va céder à la suite de de
sa fusion avec lycées eux va céder par
appartement une partie de ses actifs et
donc est ce que la partie euronext est
susceptible d'intéresser la bpi sachant
qu'il y va la compétitivité la place de
paris il ya derrière il y a le droit
d'aller les formations et cet incident
aussi important rentre-t-il
éventuellement dans la doctrine
d'intervention de la bpi mais pour le
reste je pense qu'on serait heureux
d'entendre les questions des collègues
et des raies doit commencer par les
rapporteurs merci de votre présence au
site
merci monsieur raymond vall
oui merci monsieur le président dont je
salue tous mes collègues et donc
monsieur directeur général je voudrais
vous dire que au titre de la commission
du développement durable
bien entendu nous avons deux angles de
d'attac sur cette audition à savoir bien
sûr
le fait de considérer que la bpi devra
également participer et être un
instrument majeur du financement de la
transition énergétique on aimerait bien
donc vous entendant ce sujet et bien sûr
au titre de l'aménagement du territoire
l'interrogation qui se posent dans cette
phase de démarrage de la proximité de
votre action
quels sont les partenaires avec qui vous
allez travailler et surtout le président
le vert m'a donc déjà chargé lors de
s'excuser mais de vous de vous faire
part de son impatience
quant à la création de décors et à leur
mise en place pour que vous puissiez
évidemment au niveau des régions pouvoir
traiter les dossiers qui sont parfois à
l'attendre voilà donc moi je vais être
très rapide on sur ces deux entrées
essentiel notre commission a bien nous
aurons bien sûr des échanges qui sont
attendus avec impatience
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
général du budget au choix qu'il était
important que monsieur le directeur qui
s'exprime et nous interroge ensuite à la
lumière des précisions qui leur a
souhaité nous apporter ma grand mère
merci à la burqa une sur la doctrine
d'investissement
de la bpi pour accompagner les pme
françaises et les pays à l'exportation
qu'elles sont quel va être le rôle de la
bpi pour accoter d'ubifrance de coface
du soutien des régions demain des
métropoles qu'elle sera l'action précise
de la bpi pour justement accompagner nos
entreprises à l'exportation
on sait très bien qu'il ya la chalande
essentiel on ne peut pas rester avec le
niveau de déficit du commerce extérieur
aussi abyssal que nous avons et cette
question de l'exportation est une
question importante à deuxième c'est
l'appui financier aux pme au moment bien
sûr de leur création dans les phases
ultérieures de développement et surtout
l'accompagnement vous pourrez apporter à
ces pme
on sait très bien que les aides sans
l'accompagnement n'ont pas du tout le
même impact et ne permettent pas
justement un développement dans la durée
de nos pme et quelles sont concrètement
les outils envisagés pour réussir cette
inflexion dans l'accompagnement des
entreprises et pour avoir des
dispositifs d'appui financier qui qui
évolue vers un accompagnement
personnalisé des entreprises pour qu'un
monsieur le directeur général nous avait
seule la parole mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
je suis très content de vous présenter
je vais faire très rapidement manière à
ce qu'on puisse passer rapidement aux
questions
les principaux éléments de la doctrine
d'investissement de bpi france
je vous donne en très léger
l'introduction tout de même les chiffres
de ce que nous allons pouvoir investir
entre 2013 et 2017
et cette doctrine s'applique à ces
chiffres là nous avons l'intention
d'investir de 9,2 9,2 milliards d'euros
en direct au capital d'entreprises
françaises de 2013 à 2017
ces 9,2 milliards d'euros c'est 1,7
milliard d'euros dans les pme françaises
en direct or capital risque ces 500
millions d'euros dans le capital risque
là aussi j'insiste bien c'est en direct
et ses 7 milliards d'euros
dans les autres pays les très grosses
pme et les grandes entreprises
françaises étant entendu que on va le
voir dans la doctrine d'investissement
il nous est possible de temps en temps
une fois par an une fois tous les 18
mois si nécessaire sans que nous allions
les chercher d'investir des très gros
tickets comme nous l'avons fait quand le
fsi a repris eramet à areva par exemple
quand il s'est agi de défendre valeo
contre le fonds d'investissement pardus
voilà des chiffres pour les
investissements directs pour les
investissements indirects c'est à dire
en fonds de fonds où nous mettons des
capitaux dans des fonds communs de
placement gérés par des sociétés de
gestion indépendantes privé ces 2,7
milliards d'euros sur les quatre ans qui
viennent au travers de 280 fonds privés
qui sont alimentés et co-financé par nos
équipes
voilà les voilà les grands ordres de
grandeur la doctrine qui s'applique donc
à la fois aux investissements directs et
vos investissements indirects je me
concentre sur la doctrine
d'investissement fonds propres
on pourrait parler de la doctrine de
financement j'y reviendrai mais elle est
pour l'essentiel bien connu
nous sommes des investisseurs
minoritaires
nous ne prenons pas de participation
majoritaire nous investissons dans tous
les secteurs sauf l'immobilier les
infrastructures la banque la presse les
instituts de sondage et bien entendu
nous n'investissons pas dans les
entreprises qui seraient directement
contraire à nos normes en termes de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale
je veux dire par là que il peut nous
être amené à prendre une décision
d'investissement dans une société qui
fait de l'armement ça peut arriver
simplement seront immédiatement exclu
les entreprises qui ne respecteront pas
les critères de le sg qui sont ceux de
bp france les cibles et bien vont des
tpe jusqu'aux très grandes entreprises
donc c'est tout le panorama on peut
mettre du capital auteur de deux cent
cinquante mille euros dans une toute
petite entreprise en création
cent mille euros dans un secteur
innovant internet transition écologique
biotechnologies on peut mettre un
milliard d'euros dans en l'occurrence
750 à 800 millions d'euros dans eramet
voilà donc nous ne sommes pas limités de
ce point de vue là nous intervenons en
capital risque en capital amorçage en
capital développement
nous intervenons en direct en capital
risque en capital développement
nous intervenons quand un direct en
capital amorçage
nous avons décidé que les 600 millions
d'euros du fonds national d'amorçage du
programme investissements d'avenir dont
nous sommes les gestionnaires
doivent être gérées au travers de fonds
d'investissement privés de manière à
obtenir un effet multiplicateur
important sur les 600 millions nous
avons investi déjà 313 millions dans des
fonds qui eux mêmes ont collecté de
l'argent à l'extérieur ce qui fait que
au total nous sommes à peu près à 550
millions d'euros disponibles pour les
entreprises françaises
nous avons eu nous nous intervenons dans
le segment du retournement bien entendu
mais comment le faisons nous là aussi
nous sommes là pour accompagner les
repreneurs nous ne sommes pas des
repreneurs
nous ne serons pas les repreneurs un
repreneur pour avoir une chance de
sauver une entreprise doit la prendre en
majorité on ne peut pas faire de
retournement en minoritaire
ça ne marche pas le repreneur doit
malheureusement prendre des décisions
douloureuses en général beaucoup de
licenciements des fermetures de sites
des réductions de coûts nous ne pouvons
pas faire cela en majoritaire donc nous
accompagnons des repreneurs dont c'est
le métier que de faire cela et nous les
accompagnons soit en direct soit
indirectement en finançant des fonds de
retournement privé et en faisant en
sorte que ces fonds secret ou soit même
alimenté par des ressources de
financement privé
donc nous sommes là pour animer le
secteur français des fonds de
retournement et nous ferons tout ce que
nous pourrons pour l'animer c'est un
secteur difficile même les fonds les
plus professionnels connaissent
aujourd'hui des difficultés
vous prenez des je ne veux pas citer de
noms mais vous avez des fonds qui
faisait qui font profession de ne faire
que du retournement qui aujourd'hui sont
en difficulté par que parce que
certaines de leurs participations
et bien en fait faillite le fonds
retournement le plus important que nous
finançons c'est le fcd eux qui avaient
été créées par la médiation du crédit
dont nous avons 47 %
les banques privés et mutualistes ont 53
%
c'est un fonds 300 millions d'euros nous
avons mis 150 millions d'euros
c'est un fonds qui marche bien au sens
où il fait du retournement
il a travaillé sur quatorze dossiers
aujourd'hui neuf étaient des dossiers en
livres 6 3 en fait faillite deux ont
connu un redressement spectaculaire qui
a permis de financer tous les autres qui
sont médiocres et en difficulté mais
enfin sauvée donc il ya chez bpi france
cette équipe parce que se font en
réalité il est intégré chez nous c'est
le fond dans lequel nous avons mis le
plus de capitaux un don qu'il est dans
nos équipes dans nos locaux mais nous
n'y sommes que minoritaire le comité
d'investissement du fonds est composé en
majorité de représentants de bnp paribas
de société générale de crédit mutuel
arkéa de crédit mutuel cic etc
nous portons une attention très
particulière à certains secteurs bien
entendu qui sont les biotechnologies
l'internet la transition écologique
ça ce sont les secteurs généraliste on
va dire et en termes de filières nous
avons des fonds filière et nous
continuerons d'en avoir
nous avons des fonds équipementiers
automobiles nucléaire ferroviaire bois
''mon patrimoine etc etc en direct en
indirect nous finançons des fonds
eux-mêmes spécialisée dans ce que je
viens de dire
mais également dans l'agro alimentaire
par exemple et donc nous avons une
politique de filière qui est assez assez
soutenu et qui continuera de l'être
nous mettons en place une organisation
de bpi france dans laquelle
indépendamment des organisations métier
garantie crédit fonds propre pme font 30
grandes entreprises font de fonds etc
nous avons une organisation horizontale
par secteur donc des managers dirigeants
de bpi france sont chargés d'animer des
communautés sectorielle allant de la
banque à l'investissement
nous avons des objectifs de rendement
qui sont pour l'instant avant un débat
plus poussée avec nos actionnaires
ceux qui ont été accomplis par les
entreprises dont j'ai la charge que sont
le fsi et cdc entreprises
cdc entreprises je rappelle donc que
entre 95 et 2011
les équipes ont engendré un rendement
moyen de 2 % qui est franchement un
rendement missions d'intérêt général pas
aller plus bas
pourquoi 2% parce qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup de capital risque et beaucoup
de capital amorçage qui sont les
segments les plus risqués du marché le
fsi lui fait 6 % en moyenne pour faire 6
% en moyenne
il faut aller chercher sur un certain
nombre de dossiers 15% pour financer ce
qu'ils font au moins 10 et sur lequel on
a pris des risques
donc les rendements moyens sur lesquels
on travaille aujourd'hui sont ce là les
rendements cible par entreprises sont
donc supérieurs ils doivent être
supérieurs pour financer la sinistralité
au total le retour sur capitaux investis
de bpi france en 2012
il est de 4 % ce 4% se compare à 5% pour
bpce 5% pour banque postale 8% pour bnp
paribas de mémoire et un peu plus pour
société générale 4 % on a accès à une
liquidité qui grosso modo de l'ordre de
2%
c'est la liquidité plus le coût de la
sinistralité plus importante puisque
nous allons voir des risques
significatifs plus les frais de gestion
et une petite marge qui est honnêtement
aujourd'hui relativement faible
le résultat net de 0 chaque année c'est
pour une banque qui a 30 milliards
d'euros du bilan 80 milliards 80
millions d'euros qui remontent
d'ailleurs en dividendes vers nos
actionnaires
donc on est une banque d'intérêt général
déjà les principaux indicateurs de
profitabilité ne vont pas changer en
tout cas ne seront pas dégradée par
rapport à l'état des lieux d'aujourd'hui
la discipline du résultat reste
absolument inaltérable autour de ces
objectifs là dans la doctrine
d'investissement nous intégrons
systématiquement les critères de
responsabilité environnementale sociale
et de gouvernance
nous avons dans nos investissements
directs un mental qui est nous sommes
minoritaires c'est clair mais nous avons
une culture qui est quand même d'être
aussi majoritaires que possible nous
souhaitons accompagner les entrepreneurs
être à leurs côtés on n'est pas là pour
être passifs et dormant nous sommes en
capital patient
nous sommes là pour identifier les chefs
d'entreprise masculin féminin qui seront
l'élite de l'entreprenariat français de
2020 2030 ceux qui ont décidé de se
donner des objectifs énormes parts de
partir à l'attack des géants
c'est vraiment ça qu'il s'agit les
grands ambitieux ceux qui sont hors
normes
cela on va les accompagner dans la durée
s'il faut dix ans prendra dix ans il
faut 20 ans prendra 20 ans mais on les
aidera engendré france 2030 ce qui veut
dire que même si on a 20 % du capital
seulement chez eux
on sera à leurs côtés constamment on
doit créer avec une relation de
proximité qui est plutôt une relation de
type majoritaire donc l'accompagnement
il est fondamental
il se traduit par un extrême souci de la
gouvernance des entreprises
on nomme nos administrateurs et on veut
des administrateurs de bpi france dans
les entreprises qui soit n'ont pas
surtout des policiers un qui soit
influent influents parce que respecter
des entrepreneurs et qui sont en
dialogue avec eux c'est fondamental pour
nous responsabilité sociale ça va de soi
on publie déjà chaque année mais c'est
peu connu
les créations d'emplois engendrées par
les entreprises dans lesquelles nous
sommes on va continuer de le faire
l'emploi est et est un facteur dignement
des choix d'investissement et
l'environnement également ça ça va tout
à fait de soi et tout ça sera
transparent publié avec des documents
annuels et des communications qui vous
seront adressés ainsi qu'au public
en priorité nous investissons de
l'argent dit frais c'est-à-dire des
capitaux nouveaux dans les entreprises
sous forme d'augmentation de capital
cela dit nous nous autorisons à racheter
la participation de détenteurs de
capitaux dans les entreprises dans
lesquelles nous sommes qui sont des
fonds d'investissement donc si il faut
assurer la liquidité de fonds privés on
le fera
jusqu'ici on se l'interdisent est pour
l'essentiel
considérant que notre rôle n'était pas
d'aller permettre à des fonds privés de
monétiser leur participation résultat
des courses il est arrivé souvent que de
très belles entreprises partent à
l'international parce que on se
l'interdisait on veut garder ses
entreprises en france donc désormais il
sera possible dans des cas particuliers
d'assurer la liquidité des fonds privés
il peut y avoir des exceptions à cette
doctrine sous notamment l'angle de du
sujet du majoritaire
ces exceptions seront traités en conseil
d'administration de bpi france et
devront faire l'objet d'une décision est
l'unanimité des administrateurs y
compris moi même d'ailleurs et il s'agit
de cas très très particulier où quand on
a une très belle entreprise dont on va
dire qu'elle peut être un essilor 2030
dans lesquelles nous avons nous 20% du
capital et des fonds privés en 10 10 10
et 20 les fonds privés veulent sortir
donc tout le monde sort on vend à
l'étranger et c'en est fini du rêve dans
ces cas particuliers là on peut décider
que on prend le contrôle et au bout d'un
an on recrée un tour de table français
en redevient minoritaires ce sont des
cas exceptionnels
ils passeront au conseil
d'administration puisque c'est eux c'est
une
c'est une accroche à la doctrine telle
qu'elle est présentée aujourd'hui on est
vraiment dans l'exceptionnel il s'agit
pas du tout
d'être dans le débat sur la
nationalisation de tellement de l'actif
débat qu'on a pu connaître par le passé
les décisions d'investissement sont
prises à 90 % en région
toutes les décisions d'investissements
entre rien et 4 millions d'euros sont
prises en région ce qui veut dire que
quasiment toutes les décisions
d'investissement dans les pme françaises
sont prises en région et dernier point
j'aurais insiste l'accompagnement
fondamentale et j'ajoute un notamment à
l'international pourrait prendre la
question de monsieur burquin nous avons
une philosophie qui est d'être une bande
de démarchage nous allons vers les
clients et c'est dans la cuisine des
entrepreneurs avec eux en tête à tête
que les décisions se prennent ça se
prend pas dans les bureaux d'oseo ya pas
de guichet et donc chaque chargé
d'affaires d'oseo aujourd'hui de bpi
france financement demain va voir 150
entrepreneurs par an désormais il ira
voir les entrepreneurs avec les chargés
d'affaires internationaux que nous avons
recruté chez ubifrance et qui sont
implantés maintenant dans nos directions
régionales il ira également avec les 20
salariés de coface que coface a décidé
de loger chez nous pour placer
l'assurance prospection donc notre
réseau de démarchage devient un des
grands réseaux démarchage des pme
françaises pour le placement des
services de la puissance publique
incarné par ubifrance et par coface
on ira plus loin que ça je considère que
l'accompagnement d'un entrepreneur ne
peut réellement bien se faire que par un
entrepreneur lui même les entrepreneurs
ne respecte que leurs pairs s'ils sont
une famille différente
c'est une c'est un monde et donc nous
avons aujourd'hui 2000 entrepreneurs qui
sont nos principaux clients réunis dans
oseo excellence qui va devenir bpi
france excellence
nous créerons à l'intérieur de bpi
france excellence bpi france excellence
export avec on va dire 200 entrepreneurs
qui accepteront gratuitement de donner
de leur temps pour aller parrainer leurs
leur père alors dix ans grosso modo
entre nous tu peux pas continuer comme
ça tu dois aller à l'international c'est
possible ils vont aider on va t'aider
c'est pas si dangereux que ça il ya
plein de dispositifs et toute façon si
tu le fais pas dans cinq ans plus court
de gros problèmes tu va au devant de
gros problèmes donc ça c'est ce qu'on va
faire et qu'on a lancé je m'arrête là
pour mon introduction
merci monsieur le directeur général
peut-être la parole directement sur le
rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le président raúl
puisqu'il ya plusieurs présidents
aujourd'hui trois commissions sont
associés c'est vrai que nous avons été
nombreux au moment du débat sur la
création la bpia nous intéresser à ce
dossier auquel
nous avons le sentiment qu'il faut
effectivement permettre un développement
le plus rapide possible
on avait débordé effectivement au moment
de la création que les choses aillent
vite
et de ce point de vue sur le directeur
je crois qu'on peut se réjouir de ce que
vous ayez pu prendre à bas à bras le
corps ce dossier et veiller à ce que
très vite on se met en mouvement
j'évoque par exemple cice dans lequel la
bpi a été sollicitée pour intervenir
vous nous en direz peut-être un mot tout
à l'heure mais déjà je crois 600
millions d'euros injectés pour permettre
à ce dispositif en faveur des
entreprises de fonctionner et ceci dans
des délais très rapides mais je voulais
dire aussi que vous avez su engager très
vite la mise en synergie parce qu'au
fond il ya plusieurs composantes qui
sont appelés à travailler ensemble et ce
n'est pas forcément très simple dans
toute organisation que de créer ces
synergies
les choses ont été engagées très vite et
également sur le plan de l'implication
territoriales vous avez su mettre en
place un dispositif qui me semble t'il
aujourd'hui est en capacité de répondre
aux attentes dans nos différentes
régions donc de ce point de vue je crois
que en se doit de vous féliciter de
l'engagement qui est le vôtre et de
l'efficacité de la gouvernance qui a été
mise en place depuis quelques mois
s'agissant de ce qui est le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est à dire de la doctrine
d'intervention vous avez exprimé un
certain nombre de principes qui figurent
dans ce projet de doctrine pour lequel
le parlement doit être informé
je vais interroger sur deux ou trois
points peut-être pour préciser un peu
plus les choses premier point c'est sur
le l'aspect réellement contraignant de
cette doctrine
s'agit-il de quelque chose de
véritablement contraignant pour
l'ensemble de la gouvernance ou est-ce
que c'est plutôt indicatif à ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser sur ce point si
l'ensemble des décisions d'aidé
d'intervention des différentes entités
du groupe devront s'inscrire d'une façon
un peu contraignantes dans ses principes
généraux qui sont édictées d'autre part
cette doctrine at-elle aura-t-elle un
lien avec celle du de l'agencé des
participations de l'état action de
concert d'une façon systématique ou y at
il des liens avérés formalisé quels sont
les modes de consultation réciproque
bref comment cela s'articule serti culte
il et puis enfin ce projet at il été
transmis à la commission européenne ou
bien sera ce la doctrine elle même
adopté par le conseil d'administration
qui sera transmise aux autorités
européennes nous donner une précision
sur ce point peut-être sur les éléments
que nous avez apporté concernant les
rendements vous nous avez parlé des taux
de rendement s'agissant de oséo du fsi
et d'un taux moyen de retour sur capital
de 4 %
est ce que au fond la banque aura des
objectifs chiffrés pour l'avenir en
termes de rendement pour chacune de ses
branches allant au delà de cette
statistique sur le passé est ce qu'il y
aura des ambitions clairement affichées
en particulier le groupe pourra t'il une
norme en matière de niveaux de
dividendes versés par les entreprises au
capital desquelles bpi france
investissement aura souscrit
s'agissant enfin de la sortie lorsque
bpi s'engagera dans l'ensemble
d'entreprises va contribuer à leur
développement et va sans doute certain
moment envisagé sa sortie il y aura-t-il
des objectifs en ce qui concerne la
durée minimale moyenne ou ou maximal
d'investissement au capital des
entreprises cibles j'ai bien compris
tout à l'heure dans votre exposé qu'il y
aurait sans doute du cas par cas mais il
y aura t'il néanmoins une philosophie
d'ensemble sur ses objectifs
et quels seront les critères qui vont
guider la décision de vendre des parts
est ce que c'est la conduite des projets
eux-mêmes ou est-ce que c'est plutôt un
critère fondé sur des considérations
financières sur les plus values qui vont
être réalisés ce qui permettra à bp y de
s'engager de ce projet dans d'autres
projets
bref est ce que le souci du cash va être
une préoccupation dans ses décisions de
sortie et enfin le groupe s'autorisera
t-il tout type de cession que ce soit au
travers de la bourse au travers de fonds
de capital investissement est ce que
tout cela sera possible quelle que soit
la formule utilisée
et puis enfin dernier fois monsieur le
directeur
on a le sentiment que votre organisation
va être présente dans pas mal de
conseils d'administration c'est la règle
c'est la nécessité peut se poser la
question de savoir comment le groupe
peut s'organiser pour assurer cette
présence active dans ses différents
conseils d'administration d'assez
nombreuses entreprises et ceci d'une
manière efficace il m'ya concertée et
d'une manière qui appelle certainement
la recherche d'une cohérence de la
position exprimée dans ses différents
conseils d'administration
parce que si à différentes personnes
physiques qui sillonne la france pour
être présente dans des conseils
d'administration
quand faut-il qu'elle ait une cohérence
dans leurs politiques et leurs décisions
et comment tout ça va s'articuler si
vous voyez nous préciser ça ce serait
fort utile pour nos commissions merci
merci françois marc
un accord avec les deux présidents de
commission je pense que le mieux serait
monsieur le directeur général que vous
répondiez tout de suite en france marque
pour compléter la doctrine que vous avez
exposé et les demandes de précisions du
rapporteur général du budget et après on
ouvrira le ban des prises de parole
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le sénateur rapporteur écouter
toutes ces questions sont absolument
fondamentales la doctrine c'est la loi
elle n'est pas indicatif
elle est contraignante c'est vraiment la
loi l'entreprise est désormais dès qu'on
considère qu'elle est validé par le
parlement est acté définitivement par le
conseil d'administration de bpi france
le 30 mai prochain
c'est la loi de la branche fonds propres
de bpi france
et c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
est prévu une phrase dans la doctrine
disant que dans des cas très
exceptionnels un débat peut avoir lieu
au conseil d'administration qui devra
faire l'objet d'une décision à
l'unanimité
nous avons besoin d'une voiture
maintenant lé public est en effet cette
loi très important dans le dialogue que
nous avons avec la commission européenne
dialogues qui n'est pas terminée je vais
retourner à bruxelles à la fin du mois
de mai je leur présenterai la doctrine
en en effet ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
une notification qui nous ont demandé de
faire informel c'est juste un échange de
questions réponses qui peut se
poursuivent d'ailleurs dans les semaines
qui viennent mais mais comme précisément
il nous ne sommes pas dans des délais
qui sont impératifs avec soumission d'un
dossier réponse obligatoire et bien
entre nous je m'autorise avec mes
équipes a lancé bpi france en juin
partout en france sans trop patent c'est
raison pour laquelle à partir du 3 juin
commence un déplacement dans les 22
régions françaises 22 jours ouvrables en
juin 22 régions françaises
nous allons inaugurer bpi france dans
les 22 régions
je ne dis pas inaugurer des locaux puis
s'agit pas seulement de locaux et de
lancer officiellement l'incarnation de
bpi france en rayon enfin tout ça pour
dire que la doctrine donc c'est la loi
il ya que cette loi elle sera exposée à
l'ensemble des corps constitués qui nous
observe en particulier commission
européenne mais également le conseil de
la concurrence par exemple qui nous l'a
demandé alors une question fondamentale
qui est effectivement quel est le lien
avec la doctrine de la pe et comment
est-ce qu'on s'organise avec notre
actionnaire qui l ape et comment est-ce
qu'on ait changé ce qui est des groupes
de travaux communs etc
je crois savoir que david azéma lcom sur
participations présentera au parlement
un projet de doctrine me semble t'il où
la commission des finances enfin en tout
cas il est en train de travailler sur le
sujet
nous en avons parlé lui et moi derrière
soit pas plus tard que hier soir à dîner
et
et donc je ne suis pas la pub suivant
pas là pour dévoiler la primeur des
travaux que la paix est en train de
construire mais qui sont à mon sens de
très grande qualité et qui vous
montreront que healy à emboîtement très
propre entre ce que nous faisons nous
est ce que la paix considère devoir
faire en l'occurrence nous sommes là
pour faire des pme et des tpe et faire d
eux d i avec des pme
on est fondamentalement là pour ça et
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi à l'intérieur
du fsi d'aujourd'hui dont la marque
disparaît dans quinze jours pour devenir
france investissement vous avez des
investissements dans des toutes petites
sociétés qui petit nouveau square viadeo
dailymotion jusqu'à eramet et le fsi a
beau publier doctrine sur doctrine sur
doctrine tout le monde s'est toujours
laissé finalement allé à dire mais vous
ne pouvez pas avoir d'autres et puis
vous faites tout est donc à l'intérieur
de ce qui s'appelait le fsi je crée un
fonds commun de placement à risque
99 ans 100% fonds propres des pays
consacrée exclusivement aux antilles
françaises et qui sera de 3 à 4
milliards d'euros
et donc on va non seulement on a une
doctrine mais en l'incarnent en
sanctuarisant le fléchage des fonds vers
les différentes lignes de la doctrine
3,4 milliards d'euros iront dans ce
fonds commun de placement à risque avec
son équipe de gestion on va l'appeler de
tei 2030
il est là pour faire un pays c'est pas
du tout le rôle de la pe de faire ça par
exemple à l'intérieur effet si
aujourd'hui il ya une petite équipe qui
fait du capital-risque très risqué donc
des tickets de 10 à 30 millions d'euros
dans des toutes petites sociétés pareil
on l'isolent dans un fonds commun de
placement à risque de 500 millions
d'euros on sanctuary ces 500 millions
d'euros l'un qui avec une équipe qui ne
va faire que ça il s'appellera large
venture capital risque profond va voir
comme on l'appelle
salle apple fait pas non plus la pme va
beaucoup se concentrer sur les sujets
d'infrastructures essentielles comment
est-ce qu'on travaille avec la pe
tous les jours on échange la paix est
une petite équipe nous sommes une petite
équipe et encore une fois la pe est à
notre conseil d'administration david
azéma est très présent à mes côtés dans
la construction de bpi france donc les
relations sont très forts on a on a fait
une première réunion sectorielle pour
voir comment secteur par secteur
nos spécialistes secteur et leur spécial
secteur travaillent ensemble pour
échanger nos aéronautique siens les
leurs noah et gonnot agroalimentaire les
leurs et c'est donc cesser de ses très
connecté alors les rendements la
politique de dividende sera décidé au
printemps 2014
j'ai convaincu nos deux actionnaires que
il fallait d'abord attendre d'avoir une
année propres de bpi france pour voir ce
que ça donnait avant de commencer à se
poser la question de savoir quelle
politique de dividendes on allait lui
imposé entre nous une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai souhaité qu'on reporte
ses discussions à l'année prochaine
c'est que la politique de dividende
dépend elle-même des assurances que nous
obtenons de notre actionnaire et à
d'obtention de dotation budgétaire dans
les années qui viennent pour financer
l'innovation et la garantie
nous recevons aujourd'hui nous avons
reçu pour 2013 environ 350 millions
d'euros de dotations budgétaires pour
faire innovation est garanti s'agissant
de la garantie il n'y avait rien dans le
budget il a fallu que j'aille convaincre
moi même le président de la république
de nous octroyer sur fond du pays à 150
millions d'euros pour ré alimenter nos
fonds de garantie on voit bien que si on
a la certitude en plan moyen terme de
l'état d'obtenir ces fonds qui nous
permette d'exercer notre mission
d'intérêt général
on peut remonter des dividendes très
important si on n'a pas la certitude il
faudra bien qu'on garde un peu de sous
pour financer de notre mission d'intérêt
général donc c'est que ce débat sur la
politique de dividende est fondamental
il aura lieu en avril mai 2014 et les
ambitions affichées sur le retour sur
investissement le retour sur capitaux
propres de bpi france
nous sommes à 4 % aujourd'hui avant par
parenthèse dépréciation de la
participation dans france télécom
dépréciation de 2 8 milliards d'euros
qui évidemment détruit totalement le
héros de l'année 2012 qui devient
négatif après donc mais disons que
indépendamment des provisions passées
sur les grandes lignes de participation
de bpi france
nous sommes à 4 % est ce que c est ce
que c'est le bon s'ils font pas le bon
chiffre
est ce que c'est le bon indicateur aux
pas le bon indicateur nos actionnaires
et ta caisse des dépôts et consignations
sont en train d'en discuter et on se
fixera très probablement des objectifs
spécifiques par métier la garantie et
l'innovation ça n'a pas de sens puisque
ce sont des activités subventionnaires
le crédit revanche contrat de
développement participatif crédit bail
et cetera on peut se poser la question
de savoir s'il faudrait pas qu'on soit à
des niveaux qui soit plus proche d'eux
encore une fois bpce qui est à 5.5
plutôt que 4,7 et questions qui sont
ouvertes aujourd'hui pour être très
franc
dans le domaine de l'investissement j'ai
donné les chiffres on en reste là pour
l'instant il est possible que nos
actionnaires nous demande plus nous
verrons bien
la discussion ne fait que commencer
durée minimale d'investissement n'ont en
réalité il n'y en a pas cette équipe
peut arriver il peut arriver c'est ce
qui s'est passé d'ailleurs sur
dailymotion que nous prenions du capital
dans une entreprise et que très vite une
solution de consolidation se présente
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
l'avons vendu à france télécom donc
dailymotion est resté dans les livres
que un an et demi de mémoire
et nous l'avons vendu à france télécom
dans la perspective d'un projet
industriel construit par france télécom
autour de dailymotion
voilà et contre-exemple constellium dans
lequel nous sommes nous aurions eu la
possibilité de sortir avec une énorme
plus value maintenant aujourd'hui
puisque constellium a décidé de se coter
en bourse
nous avons décidé de ne pas le faire et
de résister à la tentation de la plus
value pourquoi parce que nous souhaitons
rester un actionnaire stratégique de
constellium de manière approche à
protéger les sites français et de venir
surtout à protéger le centre de
recherche développement qui est basé en
france et c'est même plus que ça c'est
que nous avons demandé à monter notre
participation est la plus value aurait
été considérable en faisait une fois
huit ou neuf
nous sortirons cela dit de nos
participations puisque les capitaux qui
nous ont été accordés 18 milliard
d'euros et c'est définitif
on va pas nous en donner beaucoup plus
donc il faudra bien qu'on fasse tourner
le portefeuille pour qu'on puisse
réinvestir on commencera à monétiser nos
acquisitions effet si en 2016 2016-2017
2016 2017 le fsi a été créé en 2009
donc vous voyez qu'on est sur une
temporalité de 7 ans en moyenne
cela dit je répète bien que dans des cas
car dans la vie qui vont être assez
nombreux
s'il faut rester quinze ans restera
quinze ans pour aider l'entreprise à
prendre son essor
directeur le critère de sortie c'est
quand même un critère d'intérêt général
et de deux logiques industrielles plus
qu'un critère de recherche de cash avec
les assez clairement absolument
absolument le faire rapporter tout à
fait quelle présence dans les conseils
alors nous avons déjà 77 participation
du fsi dans lesquelles nous avons
injecté des administrateurs indépendants
dans certains cas il y en a deux donc
nous avons une communauté de sant
administrateurs indépendants aujourd'hui
que nous animons que j'ai réunis à un
peu plus de quinze jours
rugles il pour leur passer toutes sortes
de messages sur la création de bpi
france et que nous formons que nous
sélectionnons nous avons un annuaire
d'administrateurs indépendants
nous sommes en partenariat avec des
cabinets de chasseurs de têtes pour
repérer les meilleurs d'entre eux et
c'est comme ça que nous les attirant
dans notre communauté
c'est pour nous un vecteur de
communication très important et vous
avez tout à fait raison de dire c'est
cette communauté qui incarne non
seulement la doctrine mais notre
attitude notre code de comportement de
bpi france et c'est à eux que j'ai dit
l'autre jour je vous demande de
construire une relation personnelle avec
les chefs d'entreprises
vous avez ce devoir là cissé et c'est
ceci qui doit être votre plaisir d'une
certaine manière ça prend du temps et
mais c'est ça qui est efficace il faut
que vous puissiez les tutoyer si vous en
rester à une position distante de
représentation de quelque chose qui
représente l'état lui-même
ça ne sert pas à grand chose je vous
demande d'être là et donc on l'a fait
pour les 77 passes passion du fsi et on
le fait également pour les
participations dans les pme alors il ya
beaucoup de pme dans lequel nous n'avons
pas de représentant beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup dans les petits tickets quand
on met un million d'euros mais pas on
peut pas on investit chaque année en
direct et en indirect dans 1000 pme
françaises
il limite en revanche dès qu'on est sur
des tickets important de 4 à 10 millions
d'euros la wii bien entendu on met des
administrateurs mais je considère que
c'est fondamental ce sujet fondamental
je pense avoir répondu à vos questions
si nous allons donc ouvrir les demandes
de prise de parole je rêve en priorité
pour des contraintes horaires monsieur
moret merci monsieur le présent de
prendre en compte les contraintes
horaires ça ne tient pas à l'horaire du
repas je vous rassure mais j'ai des
obsèques dans mon département a donc je
dois repartir très vite monsieur le
directeur général merci de des
précisions que vous avez apporté je
crois qu'elles sont nécessaires parce
qu'on a tous eu ressenti une certaine
hésitation est même certain flottement
quant au positionnement de la bpi en
entendant des déclarations parfois peu
convergentes pour ne pas dire davantage
entre ces responsables moi je voulais
surtout vous vous interpellez parce que
sur le terrain
dans ma région dans mon département ce
que j'observe n'est pas tout à fait en
phase et je le regrette a exclu vous
avez dit j'observe une grande frilosité
des interlocuteurs de la bpi
j'observe une très grande lenteur dans
l'instruction des dossiers
cela étant extrêmement préjudiciable à
l'aboutissement de ces dossiers
j'ai dans mon département un dossier
très important que je vous remets très
avant de partir qui est important parce
que c'est une entreprise qui a besoin de
reprendre un site pour son développement
son développement est conditionné à la
reprise de ce site et pour le territoire
c'est un site industriel qui est
inoccupé depuis 18 mois et donc c'est
aussi très important et le les chefs
d'entreprises concernés ont le sentiment
d'avoir des interlocuteurs beaucoup
moins attentifs que dans une banque
commerciale ce qui ne devrait évidemment
pas être le cas - attentif est moins
réactif
alors moi je j'aimerais savoir le sous
directeur général d'abord comme je
voulais dix jours maîtresse dossiers
comme ça je pense qu'il sera instruite
beaucoup d'intérêt et de bienveillance
mais j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
valeur ajoutée réelle de la banque
publique d'investissement sur le terrain
pour les entreprises et pour les
territoires j'aimerais également savoir
comment vous ferez en sorte que j'ai
fini le présent que l'intérêt général
soit réellement privilégiés par rapport
comme vous l'a dit aux objectifs
financiers alors que vous avez des
actionnaires qui par définition seront
sur une autre logique
et comment faire sa dernière question
pour éviter ce ressenti que j'exprime
qui est celui aucun poids des
entreprises des élus et même des
services de l'état sur ce dossier
et j'imagine sur d'autres si peut-être
monsieur de montgolfier repréciser votre
question je vais poser tout alors
simplement savoir si la doctrine
d'intervention ex- permet d'intervenir
dans le rhône est qu on a écouté deux
banques évidemment de la parole est un
monsieur didier guillaume
monsieur de nice dans ce cas-là ce
directeur général de 500 millions
d'euros est léchée sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire les jusqu'à présent
les outils d'appui au financement de
l'innovation quelques difficultés à
prendre en compte l'innovation sociale
ténor marc est souvent remonter des
acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire le sud futur projet de loi sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire prévoit
cependant de donner un un compte auprès
six premières questions très simples
la bpi interviendra comme ans pour
soutenir ce type d'innovation quels
outils quelles moyens la deuxième
question c'est plus généralement les
structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire en raison de leurs principes
même fondateur notamment ce qui concerne
la gouvernance de gouvernance par dans
démocratique et la non lucrativité ont
beaucoup de mal à trouver des
financements alors même qu'elle
intervienne dans un champ concurrentiel
et sont capables de créer des richesses
marchande questions simples la bpi
pourra-t-elle intervenir pour soutenir
la création et le développement de ces
entreprises en particulier et j'attire
votre attention sur ce point celles qui
ont un statut associatif
merci monsieur michel teston merci
messieurs les présidents sur le
directeur général dans la doctrine
d'intervention de la bpi il est prévu
des investissements exceptionnels dans
les entreprises en difficulté
peut-on aller au delà en un visage arles
encore à titre exceptionnel des
investissements à caractère défensif en
cadeau pea ou pour s'en prémunir
l'objectif serait de maintenir ainsi en
france les centres de décision et de
recherche d'entreprise qui interviennent
dans des secteurs stratégiques et
d'éviter que des concurrents étrangers
puissent accaparer leur savoir faire
mais tellement hervé directeur général
j'ai beaucoup apprécié votre exposé vous
bénéficiez d'une authentique légitimité
d'une grande attente des compétences et
aux cibles a nécessité il y a deux
principes que vous avez cités sur
lesquels je voudrais beaucoup insisté
tout d'abord la proximité y lire dans ce
pays un double décalage qu'il nous faut
réduire premier décalage
je constate que certains acteurs
économiques verser dans un pessimisme
qui ne correspond pas à la réalité
économique et à ses points positifs et
l'on ne peut pas traverser une phase
difficile
en s'enfonçant dans une culture de la
négativité j'ai rencontré ce type de
sentiments y compris chez des directeurs
de grandes entreprises
quelquefois public du cac 40 oui aussi
lorsque je vous entendu parler
de votre tour de france mais prenez le
temps et pardonnez moi de vous dire cela
mais c'est en fonction d'une expérience
que beaucoup ici partage ne calculait
pas vos déplacements en fonction des
horaires de tgv
alors il y a aussi un second décalage
qui est très grave c'est le décalage
entre ce que l'on appelle les décideurs
les élites y compris financières
politiques et bancaires et la société ce
décalage là est mortelle quand j'ai
beaucoup apprécié ce que vous avez dit
sur les administrateurs indépendants qui
vous connaissez lorsque vous évoquez les
différents acteurs je sais bien et je
l'appuie la proximité qu'il y as avec
les régions mais monsieur le directeur
général
n'oubliez pas les grandes métropoles
car ce n'est pas un plaidoyer pro domo
que je fais l'avenir de la france dépend
de la capacité de coopération entre les
grandes collectivités région département
et métropole mais lorsque vous analysez
la capacité d'impulsion des grandes
métropoles françaises en matière
universitaire économiques technologiques
les rapports avec des entreprises
vous avez là une diversité j'ai beaucoup
apprécié ce que vous avez dit sur ce
point j'ai retrouvé ce tout simplement
la culture qui existait à la fin des
années 70 début des années 80 dans les
rapports entre la banque de france et
les collectivités terre j'ai vécu cette
culture et j'y ai participé
deuxième principe sur lequel vous avez
très justement insisté c'est la
transparence
chers collègues nous pourrons faire
toutes les lois possibles et imaginables
le problème numéro 1 essai partout c'est
la transparence y compris dans nos
collectivités et y compris bien
évidemment dans les banques
et lorsque j'évoque la transparence j'ai
une question à vous poser est ce que
dans la mission de
votre établissement vous avez une
fonction d'observation des pratiques
bancaires de la réalité bancaires et
financières françaises pourquoi je vous
parle de cela je rejoins l'intervention
de françois marc
j'aurais beaucoup de difficulté à
comprendre les efforts l'esprit de
responsabilité de la bpi si à côté il y
avait des comportements bancaires et
financiers tournant le dos à votre
logique
ce serait une forme de privatisation que
nous ne méritons pas merci beaucoup
merci monsieur de l'est merci monsieur
le président merci pour votre
intervention de son directeur une
question moi qu'il me revient que j'ai
toujours en tête c'est le capital de la
bpi
quel montant de ce capital comment il
est composé est ce que les 12 milliards
dont vous nous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'ici 2017 ces 12 milliards sur des
dotations de l'état que vous attendez ou
est ce que c'est à travers les fonds
propres
est-ce qu'il ya réellement des fonds
propres restent y en a pas et est ce que
la politique de la bpi c'est de
s'endetter ou pas à partir des fonds
propres que qu'est là où est ce qu'elle
est dans la tente de dotation et que les
engagements d'ici 2017 dépendront des
engagements de dotation que apportera
l'état ça bon c'est une question de fond
la deuxième qui rejoint une
interrogation de valérie létard que qui
pourrait pas être là aujourd'hui ma
collègue et que je donc qui m'a chargé
de demander c est ce que les régions
s'engagent budgétairement dans les
opérations ou pas est ce que tout les
toutes les structures régionales sont en
place aujourd'hui
ça rejoint un peu ce qu'a dit hervé
maurey tout à l'heure est ce que donc on
peut vous avez commencé déjà à
travailler torche toutes les régions et
enfin elle a posé une question sur le
fond de modernisation des équipements
ferroviaires qui avait été indiqué au
départ est-ce que ce fonds de
modernisation des équipements
ferroviaires va voir le jour et à quelle
échéance et avec quels moyens
merci monsieur doligé merci président je
vais vous poser une question sur le
sujet des décisions d'investissement
prix en région vous avez dit que c'est
limité à 4 millions d'euros ce qui est
très bien que ça concerne les pme
angèle plaisir avec un certain nombre de
collègues de faire des rapports sur
l'outre-mer et j'ai pu constater dans un
rapport qu'on est en train de faire sur
la défiscalisation avec serge larcher
lorsqu'on rencontre les entreprises
outre-mer elles sont très inquiète de
l'absence totale de la bpi outre mer et
compte tenu de leurs difficultés
financières actuelles très importante
des difficultés économiques de
l'outre-mer qui sont autrement plus
sérieuse ou plus important qu'au niveau
de l'hexagone
elle se demande quand l'avez pays va
arriver il ya un trou actuellement
considérable donc je souhaiterais savoir
si vous avez une projection dans le
temps de votre arrivée outre mer dernier
point pour rebondir sur la remarque
d'edmond hervé la coopération entre
collectivités me paraît importante et il
ne faudrait pas qu'il y ait un filtre
unis qu'ils soient les régions alors
tout dépend comment vous entendez le mot
région parce que c'est un territoire une
collectivité comme vous parlait d'aller
en région donc j'aimerais que l'on ne
rit pas qu'il ya d'autres collectivités
que les régions d'outremer ça tombe bien
monsieur georges patient dans la
continuité de ses obligés
oui oui c'était pour justement au fesf a
regretté le fait que le directeur
général quand il a parlé des 22 régions
françaises n'est pas mentionné les
régions d'outre-mer et parler de
l'ouverture des antennes françaises des
22 régions françaises en juin aucune
mention aux outre mer or dans la loi il
est bien fait mention que dans des pays
va s'appliquer doit s'appliquer dans les
outre mer d'après mes informations il
semblerait qu'en s'oriente vers une
simple reconduction d'une convention qui
existait entre life des lots ziio et
oseo et convention qui était très peu
appliquées mal appliquée dans la mesure
où beaucoup d'outils financiers
distribués en france métropolitaine par
oséo il n'était pas dans les outre-mer
donc est-ce que vous allez dans ce sens
malgré toutes les promesses faites d'une
application stricte en france
métropolitaine et en outre-mer
hertz
merci monsieur président même si les
moyens semblent modestes
nous avons en tout cas monsieur bien car
j'ai le sentiment que nous assistons à
la naissance d'un fonds souverain à la
française est la limite pourquoi pas si
la philosophie vous avez développé ce
qu'on essaye de développer un capital
plus stable avec les capitaux privés qui
elles peuvent s'occuper plus de la
rentabilité si cette philosophie demeure
je crois que c'est la bonne direction
enfin faut quand même rappeler que dans
la loi bancaire nous avons appris que
l'ensemble du système bancaire français
apporte 1000 milliards ensemble des
entreprises
donc ça nous met quand même les choses
en façade et certaines réalités moi j'ai
deux questions monsieur le directeur et
vous posez sur d'abord sur le 6 alors le
rapporteur général qui est mieux informé
que nous c'est normal nous indique que
vous avez financé à peu près 600
millions le problème c'est que pour
l'année ce qui est annoncé c'est de
l'ordre de nos mouvements de 20
milliards alors la question mon nous
étions surpris de voir que dans le dans
les lois de finances un apparaissait
pour financer ce dispositif
on peut comprendre techniquement qu'un
crédit d'impôt il faut déjà se voir bon
enfin c'est puis totalement un crédit
d'impôt puisqu'on à globaliser y sommes
alors j'aimerais savoir si vous avez un
conventionnement avec qui pour faire ses
avances de financement parce que il ya
un moment donné il faut bien que
j'imagine que la bb il doit rentrer dans
ses fonds ou alors c'est plus une banque
alors il pourrait nous expliquer ce que
quel type de conventionnement et combien
vous pensez devoir mettre de crédit en
oeuvre pour l'ensemble de l'année 2013
ensuite deuxième question c'est puisque
vous êtes banques liés désormais même
public
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
mesure qui en fait n'existe que dans
notre économie
fall a eu droit hier les économies
modernes nous sommes le seul pays à
disposer à disposer depuis la loi de
finances rectificative juillet l'été
dernier d'un système où on organise la
non déductibilité fiscale des intérêts
des emprunts qui sont faits par les
entreprises pour un investissement
nous avons combattu doit cette mesure ça
sera intéressant vous nous disiez
maintenant ce que vous en pensez
et si franchement dans le retournement
qui semble s'exercer pour dire on a
besoin les entreprises ça sympa une
mesure à supprimer rapidement
dernière demande de prise de parole de
chevaux grenat merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur directeur
général de la limpidité de vos propos et
de sa logique et de sa philosophie
finalement parce que ça montre au bout
du compte qu'il ya un intérêt économique
général derrière une banque publique
d'investissement
il s'est probablement ça le plus
important en même temps ça entraîne des
ambitions et des perspectives qui vont
peut-être au-delà des moyens dont vous
disposez donc il faut à la fois être
ambitieux et aussi probablement réaliste
vous aurez donc à préparer l'avenir en
soutenant dans le domaine de la
recherche de l'innovation de l'appui à
l'export un certain nombre de
d'entreprise notamment de petites et
moyennes entreprises qui peuvent
vraiment ambition devenir des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire
c'est l'aspect offensif
c'est probablement pas le plus compliqué
le plus compliqué me semble-t-il dans la
période que nous traversons et après les
chiffres qui viennent nous être
annoncées sur le taux de croissance
négatif du premier trimestre de cette
année -0 2%
c'est une stratégie que j'appellerais
plus défensif mais dans l'objectivité
conduite à dire qu'elle doit peut-être
aussi exister même si elle est
momentanée nous connaissons sa tante
d'entreprises en particulier des pme qui
ont des difficultés de trésorerie patate
passagère et qui pour autant une
capacité à rebondir et qui sont
financièrement saine aussi ce qu'ils
peuvent être efficaces et donc est ce
que vous imaginez dans le cadre de vos
stratégies diverses une stratégie
défensive
qui permettent de soutenir des
entreprises de manière momentanée
considérant que ces difficultés ne sont
que passagères et ne met pas en cause
l'efficacité la réalité de économique de
ces entreprises deuxième aspect c'est
sur le
sur la simplification de l'ensemble des
dispositifs
il me semble que l'ensemble des
dispositifs lorsqu'ils existent de
soutien financier
tous nos réseaux de pme est souvent
extrêmement complexe parfois prennent
énormément de temps et donc la
simplification des dispositifs ma part
est également extrêmement importantes
ainsi que la réactivité
enfin dernier point c'est sur la
gouvernance vous savez qu'un certain
nombre des régions se sont beaucoup
impliqués dans le cas de soutien aux
petites et moyennes entreprises petites
et moyennes industries également
notamment lorsqu'il s'agissait de mise
en place de de soutien à l'industrie
il me semble qu'il serait pas
inintéressant alors je suis bien entendu
l'aspect évoquée s'agissant des
métropoles des départements aussi mais
il me semble qu'en termes de compétence
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui quelque
elles vont être probablement renforcés
demain ce sont plutôt les régions qui
auront la compétence économique
ce qui ne signifie pas bien entendu que
les régions seul doit faire sans prendre
langue avec les départements et les
métropoles ça me paraît une évidence
mais ne pensez vous pas qu'en termes de
gouvernance il sera intéressant
d'imaginer aussi une coco gouvernance
baby région avec chaque région française
de manière à ce qu'ils aient une logique
de codécision et de co investissement
parce que la bpi peut investir les
régions aussi ce qui peut entraîner de
facto du reste c'est ce qui s'est
produit très concrètement pays de la
loire à partir du moment où la région
investit à partir du moment où oseo à
l'époque l'avait fait systématiquement
le système bancaire rassurer d'une
certaine manière est venu au pot commun
pour soutenir les pme et donc ne pensez
vous pas que
forme d'une formalisation d'une co
décision d'une co décision
d'investissement également serait d'une
certaine d'une certaine efficacité enfin
dernier point j'ai bien noté que c'était
que de manière exceptionnelle que la bpi
pouvait intervenir
s'agissant notammment et j'ai su le
président mam m'a troublé pardonnez-moi
sur un dispositif donc j'en reste là
respectives le temps de parole jeu
viendra notamment
excuse-moi yannick monsieur directeur
général pour finir cette salve eu de
questions et d'interrogations mais c'est
rejoint certain nombre d'interrogations
qui a été posée je prendrais simplement
sur l'aspect innovation ou où va se
gérer le soutien aux entreprises de
recherche sous contrat qui était piloté
par oseo
autrement dit ces 10 millions annuels
qui valait piloter vis-à-vis du
dispositif de fusion interactions entre
les différents organismes
merci monsieur le directeur de répondre
à cet ensemble d'interrogations qui vous
ont été posées vous avez seule la parole
alors donc j'ai le dossier de la société
qui était indiqué en référence tout à
l'heure on la connaît bien de notre ami
est parti tant que je je je traite à
reculer mais français d'un dossier tout
à fait caractéristique de notre vie
quotidienne une entreprise qui va quand
même pas bien où il est question de
cofinancer avec une banque et la banque
qui écrivait ricol se fait tirer
l'oreille parce que le cas est un cas
vraiment de la zone grise alors euronext
oui euronext je pense que oui fait
partie d'eux
du périmètre et vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire qu'il ya potentiellement
un sujet intéressant les stratégique
économie sociale et solidaire
alors ce qui a été décidé entre nous et
la caisse et que la caisse garder le
réseau de contacts avec le monde de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
l'initiative france france active
hallyday ce au travers de ses directions
régionales nous n'avons pas nous n'avons
pas chez bpi france dans les directions
genin d'oseo l'équipement et les
individus permettant de
de prendre ce relais là et la caisse le
fait très bien
donc la caisse finance initiative france
finance france actifs financent hallyday
ce finance le crédit coopératif est ce
que on apporterait une couche
supplémentaire du financement c'est
possible c'est à discuter entre nous et
notre actionnaire qu'est ce il faudra en
tout état de cause que ce soit
parfaitement coordonné la caisse nous
transfère dans les apports les fonds
qu'elle a injectés dans des fonds privés
consacré à le ss gérés par amundi
société générale etc
donc nous avons une activité de fonds de
fonds économie sociale et solidaire et
nous allons la renforcer voilà soit ce
que je peux dire à ce stade qui est très
important il faut se souvenir que c'est
difficile d'injecter du capital dans des
coopératives
parce que on ne sait pas comment sortir
ensuite il faut avant soit aux salariés
soit revendre à la coopérative mais il
ya des sujets de liquidités qui sont
très compliquées et donc c'est pour ça
que le capital-développement le capital
investissement dans le monde coopératif
a toujours été difficile c'est pas pour
ça qu'on va pas en fait on en francs
mais ce sera forcément dans des
proportions plus faibles que pour le
capital développement normal
investissements dans des entreprises qui
font l'objet d'une opa et et qui sont
stratégiques pour la france
on l'a déjà fait avec danone et avec
valéo on le refera il n'y a pas de doute
là dessus on vient de le faire sur
technicolor
on est monté au capital de technicolor
on a pris pratiquement 10% capter le
technicolor c'est précisément pour faire
passer un message qui est que nous ne
souhaitons pas que cette entreprise soit
démantelée
c'était il ya trois semaines proximité
donc les les questions du chanteur hervé
fondamental il ya 4,4 valeurs affichées
dans bpi france qui sont le support de
la marque et qui seront sur tous les
murs de bpi france à partir du lancement
de la marque de 3 juin c'est proximité
simplicité optimisme et volonté voilà
les quatre valeurs de l'entreprise
je pense que on est donc assez d'accord
avec avec monsieur gervais et notamment
sur la partie optimisme puisque ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui est en effet c'est
le grand paradoxe c'est que il ya
beaucoup d'argent à investir en france
il ya des idées partout le crédit
bancaire aux pme est le moins cher
d'europe moins chère d'europe
il est 80 points de base 0 8 % en
dessous de la moyenne du crédit bancaire
aux pme allemandes
donc les réseaux bancaires se font une
compétition sont en ce moment d'ailleurs
absolument féroce sur les taux les taux
ont beaucoup baissé
le crédit dont le crédit qui n'est pas
disponible c'est là c'est la trésorerie
mais le crédit développement matériel
immatériel il
l'equity et là ce qui est pas là c'est
le moral et on le constate tous les
jours tous les jours donc les agents de
bpi france en région ont un devoir dans
leurs démarches
leur politique commerciale de démarchage
qui est justement d'aller avec avec
volonté et optimisme expliqué que c'est
le moment d'investir c'est le moment
d'aller l'international les conditions
sont réunies la reprise reviendra et
donc ils sont ils sont une armée hostile
au discours de la négativité et moi je
les guide dans cette direction là c'est
absolument essentiel
je suis bien d'accord avec vous que dans
les entreprises du cac 40 on se laisse
un peu aller les métropoles
oui on travaillera bien entendu avec
elle il se trouve que les fonds communs
d'innovation de garantie et de
financement sont bâties avec les
conseils régionaux
on n'en a pas fait avec les métropoles
ni initiative n'a jamais été prise ni
par l ni par nous mais c'est pas
totalement tapuach n'essayez pas
totalement impossible
ces poussées complètement dans les pures
transparence on sera aussi transparent
que possible
on lancera en novembre ce que j'ai envie
d'appeler le le think tank bpi france
c'est à dire le lieu où on doit tout
obtenir et tout savoir du monde de la
pme françaises on a accès à des données
d'une profondeur incroyable au travers
d'oseo au travers de cdc entreprises et
au travers du fsi
ces données sont traitées par des
services différents que je fusionne dans
une grande direction des études mais
comme je veux qu'elle soit totalement
ouverte dans le jargon montviel on
appelle ça l'open data d'une certaine
manière
bon donc c'est en fait un
un centre de ressources et d'information
et de réflexion sur la pme et le deal
française ouverte et on le lance en
novembre à l'occasion de la publication
de toutes nos grandes études sur les
hôtels les pme l'étude annuelle etc
c'est très très important et c'est
d'ailleurs pascal lagarde qui est là et
qui sera à la manoeuvre pour relancer ce
projet le capital de la bpi les fonds
propres d'oséo demi heure et demie les
fonds propres de france investissement
18 milliards d'euros voilà ça ce sont
les deux chiffres 10 8 milliards donc
les 12 milliards à investir dans les
années qui viennent ce sont les 18
milliards de fonds propres de france
investissement qui eux mêmes vont
tourner par l'effet de monétisation dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure le fond
ferroviaire on le lance en juin 40
milliards da 40 millions d'euros
et donc ça c'est parti est-ce qu on
s'endette ou pas pour faire plus de
capitaux propres enfin plus
d'investissements en fonds propres
la réponse est non en revanche on va
chercher de la liquidité sur le marché
bien entendu pour faire nos crédits
bancaires on lève à peu près chaque
année 4 à 5 milliards d'euros sur les
marchés mondiaux
on l'élève en ce moment à des taux
incroyablement bas puisque c'est aux
athées +18 points de base on est avec
garantie implicite de l'état par la
cascade ddd détention capitalistique
mais il n'y a pas de garanties écrites
40 millions le fonds ferroviaire qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec 40 millions eh bien
on fait on fait 5 tickets de 5 millions
d'euros
on se dira toujours une marge de
manoeuvre pour pouvoir réinvestir dans
les entreprises après donc le ce qu'est
ce qui a été conçu dans le fond
ferroviaire avec nos partenaires
elle a été en anticipant sur la demande
donc on a bien regardé quels étaient les
cibles qui était potentiellement
intéressés par ce fonds spécialisés et
on arrive grosso modo à un besoin
il n'y a pas d'infrastructures lasser
les entreprises qui font du matériel
nous on ne fait pas si vous l'avez dit
ou les trois structures mais parce que
vous y toucher maintenant
l'infrastructure c'est la pe ou la
caisse à mes collègues à la caisse la
caisse à à fond n'a pas soutenu ce qu'on
reçoit au pied de l'autre mère donc on a
eu des discussions je suis très aligné
avec votre position je la pousse
simplement je ne suis pas maître de la
décision de meditel est donc en ce qui
ce se qui se détaillent et se décide en
ce moment c'est de savoir si bpi france
intervient en direct dans toutes les
régions d'outremer temps certaines
d'entre elles en particulier et guyane
ou bien si on en reste avec
l'intermédiation de l'afd ou bien si on
retient une solution intermédiaire qui
consisterait de passer par les
directions régionales de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations qui aurait donc
au cas particulier un département qui
s'appellerait bpi france métisse raid
dans la direction régionale de la caisse
le trésor est en train de travailler sur
le sujet voilà la soupe est en train de
cuire mais je suis bien d'accord avec
vous je suis bien d'accord avec vous moi
je suis je suis prêt depuis un bout de
temps monsieur le théâtre le sait bien
et j'ai eu un dialogue est finalement
assez constructif avec le pas avec le
patron de l'afd sur le sujet donc c'est
un vrai sujet de küttel maintenant que
nous attendons un fonds souverain à la
française vous suit
pour qu'on est d'accord le cic le cic 20
milliards d'euros
là je pense qu'il faut faire attention à
la perception sur les chiffres il ya le
crédit d'impôt qui représentent 20
milliards d'euros
il n'a jamais été dit qu'on allait
priver que que les entreprises
françaises allaient demander le
préfinancement de 20 milliards d'euros
sur les 20 milliards d'euros il y en a
10 milliards pour les grandes
entreprises françaises qui n'ont pas de
problèmes de trésorerie qui ont
absolument pas besoin de préfinancer il
y en a 10 milliards pour les pme et sur
les 10 milliards de pme on a considéré
que seul le 2 milliards avait besoin
d'un préfinancement donc le marché du
préfinancement du cic e sur 20 milliards
ces deux et sur les deux on a dit que
oseo ferait entre 800 millions et un
milliard d'euros de crédits en direct et
un milliard d'euros de crédit bancaire
privée garanti donc par rapport à ces
deux milliards là on est dans le budget
aujourd'hui
la non déductibilité fiscale des
intérêts là je ne me lève pas au dessus
de ma condition
ce n'est pas mon sujet voilà donc je
botte en touche
si vous me permettez la non
déductibilité fiscale des intérêts je
dis que je ne me lève pas au dessus de
ma condition
mais oui mais le soutien transitoire des
entreprises saines qui ont des
difficultés passagères c'est vraiment
notre vie quotidienne ça c'est à dire
que le la culture d'oseo
c'est vraiment d'aller jusqu'au bout de
ce qu'on peut faire quand il faut donner
un coup de main et quand on peut pas on
peut pas et il a raison pour laquelle
oseo le fait qu'en d'autres banques ne
le font pas c'est que oseo a capitalisé
une culture pme la culture du directeur
financier du daf de pme 360 degrés qui
comprend comment ça fonctionne on lâche
et oseo dont beaucoup d' agences
bancaires
on l'a moins maintenant malheureusement
la gouvernance avec les régions
codécision co-investissement cantons
cofinancent ont co décident canton
confidences pas on peut pas qu'aux
décider
c'est aussi simple que ça donc les fonds
les fonds régionaux cofinancé par eux et
nous
co décident tous les fonds de garantie
régionaux qui sont opérés par nous tout
est codé six départs échanges d'e-mails
dans la journée entre professionnels les
fonds d'innovation c'est pareil et
franchement je trouve que ça fonctionne
bien ça fonctionne de manière
extrêmement fluide c'est pas des comités
c'est pas des gros dossiers qui sont
échangées cd email c'est l'intelligence
collective moderne alors les entreprises
de recherche sous contrat
et il l'est toujours
oui rien ne change de ce point de vue là
à oséo continue de gérer ce fonds la
gerle easyshare le f lui gère les psp
fait va gérer le fonds d'innovation
rupture tout ça suit son cours puis
directeur je crois être le porte parole
de mes collègues de voir de vos réponses
précises net est en tous les cas de
votre disponibilité
c'est très intéressant d'avoir une
audition de ce type et je vous remercie
tous les cas je suis persuadé que nous
aurons l'occasion de nous revoir sans
doute au bout d'un an de fonctionnement
et après que vous nous ayez exposer
votre politique de voir le bilan bout
d'un an et je suis persuadé que avec la
commission des finances serrées
commission de développement durable de
faire le diagnostic de fonctionnement et
et en particulier remontées du terrain
que nous aurons eu nous les élus voilà
merci monsieur le directeur 30 ans
voilà pour l'audition de nicolas
dufourcq le directeur général de la bpi
si vous souhaitez revoir cette audition
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
journée à tous